alors on a fait un petit top comme pour
le le secret story qui en avaient après
non ses
[Rires]
services voilà sur notamment les
coulisses du resto du coeur en fait
voilà comment ça s'est passé comment est
née l'idée
alors là j'ai fait un gros flash back
ouais ça se plaçait en 85 au moment où
il faisait super froid l'hiver 85 et on
était un jour en après midi chez lui il
me dit dont tu vois il ya des gens qui
arrivent pas à manger à leur faim regard
la joie payer mes impôts ils devaient
payer une grosse somme d'impôts il me
dit tu te rends compte si on signe si on
s'y mettait à plusieurs tous ceux qui
gagnent du pognon comme moi en france
parce qu'il gagnait beaucoup d'argent on
pourrait 1 les problèmes parce qu'à
l'époque on estimait à peu près 200
mille personnes qui ne mangent pas à
leur faim ça a augmenté après l'hiver
enfin non en général quoi voilà et donc
il me dit bon bah regarde qu'est ce
qu'on fait là il commence à se dessiner
un truc guy drouillard machin dessine
une sorte de plateau comme dans un avion
là il me dit mon maître à la vie en leur
mettrais légumes etc 05 toi
à l'époque il était un peu dans le trou
savez qu'il ya eu une période brullemans
c'est moi est un peu dans le trou et je
commence à me renseigner j'appelle m o
georges secrétaire le collier je me fais
tech de partout avant ma main sur quatre
de coluche à l'est
pour aller dans l'agroalimentaire ses
soeurs saltimbanques et agroalimentaire
a priori c'était pas évident le lien et
puis bon on n'en parle plus mais bon il
y pense et j'y pense et puis neuf mois
après alors là on tenait d'organiser le
record du monde de moto on revient je
reviens c'était moi qui ai caprica murs
et les motos je reviens au bureau et un
repas on avait une émission à l'époque
sa poche en souvenez s'appelait y en
aura pour tout le monde je rentre dans
le bureau une dit signe là à ce moment
là j'ai une sorte d'intuition j attends
de quoi tu me parles tu me parle pas du
truc de beauf qu'on avait dont on a
parlé ya s'il ya un manque d'imams bien
sûr et puis le relâche donc je cynthia
secrétaire général et lyon on a des
statuts les statuts au comment savait
pas comment faire les statuts d'une
association
on les a pompé sur ceux d'une boîte de
nuit un appel au privé ouais ouais alors
la fed et sert et d'associations qui
veut partir
oui c'est les restaurants du coeur pas
du coeur les emplois et puis là on est
parti et on est parti et on l'a fait il
ya eu la fameuse photo sur les toilettes
aussi qu'ils étaient très célèbre celle
là aussi c'est pareil c'est sur les
toits ne savait pas qui était sur les
toilettes à ce moment-là cadeaux
officiels de la photo officielle telle
la bastille et alicia il s'en est allé
aux toilettes ça a été fait à cannes
dans le hall du martinez c'est vrai il a
chié dans le hall
d'une théorie comme quoi gazon le
photographe galère est tellement fallait
trois enfants tous que quand il l'a
chopé il y avait moi les chiottes où il
pouvait être tranquille c'est quoi ça
sort d'où sa non alors là ça c'est un
mensonge gens sérieux rabat l'histoire
était belle oui je sais pas je préfère
bien là tu avais pas alors pardon aussi
on nous dit ah ça je le dis mais je ne
sais pas du tout il a tout fait pour
être en surpoids il n'était pas gros à
la base du tout il est voulu se donner
un personnage ça c'est encore une
connerie c'est pas totalement une
connerie disent ah ouais c'est parce que
moi je les ai connus à lâcher la faille
connue à l'encan moi je dit nadal et
andre kelly sera relais connu j'avais 16
ans pourra rire aujourd'hui j'en ai 70
donc lui il avait huit ans de plus que
moi il était on va dire ils étaient ils
étaient minces ouais mais quand même un
tout petit peu en retard il sait parler
avec un prêtre grossi pour créer ce
personnage
voilà qu'il a commencé à créer le
personnage qui a été connue par le
sketch l'histoire d'un mec ouais
effectivement bon comme son école
ç'avait été le cap et théâtre avec
romain bouteille et c'est qu'il avait
compris que son personnage que la
rondeur permettait elle va le faire
mieux passer comique
ou un petit que ses postures il écope il
est copié sur une star américaine comme
elle s'appellerait elizabeth taylor un
ouais il atteint mais posture voilà
c'est à dire qu il prenait toujours le
contre-pied de ce qu'il était je sache
je ne savais pas après effectivement
lieu le mariage etc tirer leur ont alors
eux aussi plus tard et a fait un
scandale beaucoup plus tard barre 80 il
n'aurait jamais pu faire les restos du
coeur savait pas autour de lui des
vedettes qui ont médiatisé
halima et sa ruse ou mais non mais si
vous voulez quand on crée les restos du
coeur au départ n'y a pas de vedette
quand les jeunes savent que qui veut
créer ça effectivement comme il était
vachement aimé et pour cause parce que
c'était un mec qu'on avait envie d'aimer
les gens vont se rassembler rassembler
pardon est un acte évident à la collecte
à europe 1 pardon mais qui n'y croyait
pas ou qui ont pas voulu tout sa mère
qui la presse qui attaquait mais david
toute une page bien sûr vous avez toute
une partie de la presse de droite qui
attaquait il veut se faire de la pub et
une partie de la presse de gauche aussi
qu est attaqué en disant de toute
manière c'est à l'état de faire ça
d'accord qui fait qu'au début quand on
crée les restos du coeur on est dans une
grande incrédulité d'où il va se passer
quelques histoires donc peut-être tu te
souviens avec quelques journalistes qui
sont là sont attendues tant sur 10 ha
est bien connu comme en souvenir bah non
non je n'étais pas non
j'étais une jean luc et oui donc voilà
j'ai pourtant eu
excusez moi pour les autres alors il se
présente aux élections on avance un
petit peu c'était un film qui a été
organisée mais elle apprend sa part de
rui pardon j'ai avant tout se méfier
visa avant les restos du coeur savant
qui meurent dont effectivement restos du
coeur c'est un andy murray ont 85 85 et
me regardant 26 et les délais que la
campagne présidentielle c'est à dire
qu'on va 80 comme ce
qui a été fait par antoine de caunes sur
cette partie justement de sa vie oui
voilà que très bien d'ailleurs et donc
il est taillé avait atteint jusqu'à 16%
à peu près d'autres d'intention de vente
de notre pardon à ce moment là vous vous
êtes encore très proche de lui mais
j'étais son secrétaire pendant la
campagne présidentielle d'accord et dans
la plaie son bureau politique ambulants
vrai que voir donc vous vous êtes
régulièrement
parce qu'on le voit dans le film - et
comment ça commence à changer commence à
briller ou les renseignements généraux
commencent elle a dû réveiller vous avez
une censure ouais décidées par le sommet
de l'état pour vous empêcher de parler
et que au départ vous êtes partis sur
une farce qu'en plus il va se passer un
drame qui est la mort d'un de nos amis
très proches qui était le régisseur mais
il va faire qu'il n'avait rien à voir
l'une à flers on va dire passionnel bon
mais ont ravi tout d'un coup dans une
ambiance qui fait plus du tout la
rigolade ouais 4 la campagne
présidentielle on a démarré parce que
c'est la plus belle plaisanterie qu'on
avait
pouvait le faire parce que lui dans sa
tête il disait si je fais 2 % c'est
génial et là il a 16 et là bon 16 c'est
vraiment le journal du dimanche qui
s'est un peu énervé
le 2 et le 11 9 c'est le premier qui a
été très bien train d'expliquer dans le
film c'est qu'il ya un moment c'est un
peu émouvant aussi dans ses campagnes
ses cheveux au vent lui j'aime ou je
suis pas sûr que non
il y avait des princes qui était un peu
les mêmes c'est je vais à la rencontre
des gens et ils me disent mais se sauver
nous sauver nous nous on croit en vous
les phrases qui sortait zemmour c'est
celle qu'on attend d'un film un petit
peu et une fois que tu as connu ce que
trouver ce qu'elle faisait ça pour rire
se retrouve devant des gens qui n'ont
rien et qui lui disent nous on veut
vraiment tu es un peu compliqué quand
même des moussanais qui
veut dire que pour nous oui merci non
mais tu vois ce que je veux dire c'est
que tirer dans la rue veut dire aussi
bas mais mon petit écoutait beaucoup
prandelli des
trois mètres d'investiture de mer un
goupil a bien précis mobilité il était
acculé de tous les sens serait ce que la
gauche me sentais qu'on en avait 6 ans
34 il a fait une conférence de presse
est alors en plus moi il m'avait dit tu
vas dire parce qu'en plus il voulait que
je fasse une déclaration russe parce
qu'on lui disait vous faites le jeu des
russes mais en réalité on avait 11
signature donc on avait fait une fausse
pile avec plein de trucs dont est au
dessus on avait mis 11 mai 11 signature
mais cela dit la campagne de démarchage
des signatures il n'a pas vraiment fait
c'est à dire que c'était quelque chose
si vous voulez le grand punta
candidature de coluche est quelque chose
qui partait de la base vers le haut vous
aviez des centaines de comités de
soutien qui s'était fait dans toute la
france et nous on attendait que ça
remonte alors oui ce que je veux dire
c'est bien sûr du tout mais une vision
de partie voilà oui il aurait pu aller
plus loin si et des deux côtés il n'y
avait pas eu de dakota et mitterrand qui
avait peur qu'on lui pique ses voix bah
finalement mitterrand luis celada gauche
et rend c'est le seul qui a fait une
déclaration qu'il a voulu faire une
alliance il aurait aimé par une alliance
mitterrand il a envoyé jacques attali
pour que pour essayer de comprendre de
quoi il a retourné pas si commerçants et
bien que s'inquiéter le peuple de france
et avait aller vers coluche et en même
temps forcément gérard zone est alors
charles charras kg rester beaucoup
pourraient alors ces techniques dont
elles sont là non ma fille tu
m'intéresses accolades dans pardon jean
michel de revenir là dessus mais excusez
moi je
sais à quel point il était surveillé il
y avait des camions devant chez lui oui
ce qu'on appelle des sous marins les
renseignements généraux il le sua est
partout et qui essaie de faire des
saloperies sur lui là sont là il a un
petit peu aussi une cellule du ministère
de l'intérieur qui avait été dédié à
empêcher la candidature de coluche
s'accroît et donc qu'ils ont mis les
moyens qu'il fallait les lettres de
menace ou la question de ravine chic
votre intime conviction il a toujours
toujours été dit que cet accident de
moto avec le camion qui arrive comme ça
il a toujours été dit que
c'était peut-être
pas tranché oui mais revient d'une
grande chaîne qui a duré un an et qui a
dit que c'était un accident cela dit si
vous me demandez mon intime qu'on a eu
on voit là je vous dirais que je pense
que jusqu'à mon dernier jour on aurait
le doute mais surtout pas qu'ils avaient
reçu des plombs mais il avait reçu des
petits cercueils et ses copains qu'avait
cette histoire de son ingé-son de son
je ne serai plus le réseau c'est en
lumière non qui avait dégringolé à
thaksin et koné gorlin étaient
assassinés pendant la campagne
présidentielle de 80 81 et vous avez
également un passionné gore là on a des
eaux il ya eu à l'époque des ordres pour
qu'on ne fasse pas dans la tête tout de
suite pour laisser une odeur on va dire
sulfureuses sur la campagne d'accord un
an après ils ont découvert qu'ils
avaient commis ce meurtre compris et que
ça n'avait rien à voir sinon je n'ai
rien à bord mais oui mais c'est arrivé
au mauvais moment à soi mais c'est quand
même hyper élite et on va dire
instrumentalisé moi c'est quoi r ce qui
est très drôle aussi c'est que hank donc
en 183 je crois qu'il a son césar pour
tchao pantin ouais et à ce moment là en
fait trop 24 passes 84 les tournants 80
tout ce film génial je pense qu'on a
tous vu ou à peu près il est très très
mal dans ce final sa femme l'a quitté
lui il est tombé un peu dans la drogue
elle a quitté depuis depuis 81 ça va
être comme je
[Rires]
l'aimé comme ça maintenant je sais bien
mais là vraiment
ils sont
180 483 il a quitté sa femme mince et sa
femme qui l'a quitté ecoutez jean michel
cunin n'a donc du covan ils sont plus
ensemble ils essaient de tournage de ce
film apparemment il est très très mal
lui oui au plus mal n'arrive pas à toi
là il est mal de dents il arrive même
pas à tourner les scènes c'est vrai tout
çà banon
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
cette période où il était pénible à
interviewer parce qu'on ne savait jamais
dans quel état d'esprit on aller le
trouver je suis tout à fait d'accord au
loup jean mi si je peux me permettre
d'avoir des dates revin en gros à 84 et
elle va tomber dans l'héroïne a fait
savoir à la ccin n'était pas très bien
alors oui quand même un pardon bah oui
ça a du bon au moment où ils tournent
show pantin il est encore temps d'en
sortir et pour faire le personnage parce
que c'est un personnage draps
l'alcoolique d'une éponge alcoolique il
va fumer des pétards toute la journée
pour donner le pouls pour être dans le
web voilà oui mais à l'époque il a
arrêté l'héroïne à d'accord et c'est au
moment où va créer les restos landes est
complètement sorti d'un grand sorte de
renaissance à il devait trop nerveux
quand même wen d'arrêter well être un
peu nerveux si je n'avais qu'une ruine
marisa anconina raconte que la scène de
la claque il la donne vraiment
absolument quelle scène de la cac et
véridique sa racine ici on connaît la le
dit oui monsieur français en cognant qui
dit quelque chose
c'est pas moi qui ai pris la claque jeu
plaisant à bout de virement